hello and welcome to the new world
review your cells for everything anime
and manga but today it seems to be your
source for everything on to Hunter
because it's time for some more
discussion about quote-unquote current
events and for this video I figured that
we'd actually get into what we know
about the Dark Continent itself and this
is because a succession war is cool and
all I don't want to forget our main
long-term focus here because the Dark
Continent is location that has inspired
my imagination ever since I first heard
about it and it continues to be a
profound driving factor for my interest
in the current manga events to this day
and despite it being a mysterious and
massive chunk of land we do actually
know a surprising amount about it
including what sort of life inhabits it
and who over the course of human history
has been there as well as of course the
horrors they brought back to the human
realm which speaking of there's a good
place to start for much of the lifespan
of hunter hunter this was the world map
a collective of six continents that
housed an incredible two hundred fifty
countries surrounded by what was thought
to be an ocean however in reality we
actually cannot call all this blue stuff
here you see an ocean because it does
not meet the technical definition a more
accurate label would be a lake a lake
nestled within a truly massive expanse
of land known as the Dark Continent
now this patch of water does have an
actual name which is like mobius named
of course for shape which resembles a
mobius strip and right in the center of
Lake Mobius is the known world the
separation of which from the Dark
Continent via the lake is undoubtedly
the only reason why the human race has
managed to survive and thrive to modern
day also I guess if you wanted to get
technical then we could say that we've
been on the Dark Continent
ever since the series began but despite
humanity's separation from this larger
landmass the curiosity of humans has
always led them to pushing every
boundary possible and eventually
discovering that they were a teeny tiny
grain of sand in a truly extraordinary
world although traveling across such a
large stretch of water has not been
possible for humankind due both to the
sheer amount of distance needed to cover
as well as the threats laying in wait in
the lake however this does not mean
traveling to the Dark Continent was
impossible
far from it actually because there is a
how shall we put this I suppose we'll
call it a the conventional method of
gaining access to the llamas but in
order to achieve this a person must
contact a race of magical beasts known
as the gatekeeper which is said to be a
clan with a pipeline to the Dark
Continent
and who summon another being known as
the guide to escort individuals to the
continent and sadly that is about the
extent of the knowledge we have
regarding them at the moment however it
would seem that all human travelers have
had to invoke their services in order to
reach the continent
and humanity has known about the Dark
Continent for quite some time as it has
been mentioned in ancient texts
primarily in reference to the
unmitigated disasters that occurred
every time people journeyed there with
that said when it comes to the Dark
Continent
there is one text unrivaled amongst all
others which is a traveler's journal
entitled journey to the new world
authored by a man named Don freaks over
300 years ago which details his
adventure across the shoreline of Lake
Mobius well they're quite
problematically the work is split up
into two volumes being the east and west
addition detailing the east and west
halves of the lake maybe a shoreline
respectively however only the east
addition has been found leading to a
couple of theories as to the missing
West volume first and most boring of all
is that it simply hasn't been found yet
the second is that Don Freaks was far
too ambitious and was never able to
cover the entire continent shoreline in
his lifetime and the third and most
interesting is that because this
landmass is so large
Don Freaks is still currently writing
the West edition which yes would make
him well over 300 years old but with
some of the stuff we're about to examine
about the Dark Continent that will
probably strike you as one of the less
impressive feats one may be able to
achieve Don is of course not our only
source of information on the continent
though and we actually do have a
first-hand account from a very familiar
character by the name of Isaac Metro who
travelled to the continent not once but
twice although one of these trips was
unofficial and on that particular trip
he was accompanied by his two friends
Zig zoldak and Lynn who has a horrendous
last name to pronounce I'm not even
going to try well though an eye the trip
was able to satisfy heteros personal
needs as he was always in search of a
powerful opponent and according to him
the only victory available on the dark
continent was that of survival but
notorious experience led him to lobbying
the v5 which are the ruling body of
nations in the human realm and they went
on to establish what is known as the
inviability treaty which strictly
prohibited any travel to the dark
continent in order to protect not only
those who would venture out but also to
protect the human race at large in fact
even members of the hunter Association
were forbidden access to this area of
the world however that was never going
to stop the inquisitive minds of mankind
and while it is difficult to know how
many of these excursions took place
after the ban according to the available
data ventures to the continent have been
conducted on at least 149 separate
occasions and I do want to stress that
this number is likely significantly
larger due to the unknown quantity of
unofficial trips because the big problem
integrals traveling to the dark
continent is that the overwhelming
amount of explorers never returned in
fact of all of these
Voyager's only five succeeded in making
a round-trip consisting of a grand total
of 28 survivors of these survivors all
of whom represented the peak of humanity
with the fitness level of Olympic
medalists only three of them were able
to return to their daily lives
unaffected by their encounters on the
continent and only one of whom is still
alive to this very day who is a man
named beyond knit or the son of Isaac
nutter and we'll get back to him because
he is the key driving force behind this
entire story arc I do also want to
quickly point out that this number of
survivors does not include Lin who
accompany Ned to wrote on his unofficial
trip and who therefore should be
rightfully counted as a survivor but for
now you may be starting to ask the
question of why people continue to
venture out to the Dark Continent
knowing how though the survival rate was
and to put it very simply it's because
it was a high-risk high-reward venture
as this landmass possesses nothing short
of incredible power for humankind to
harness and all five of the unofficial
but quote-unquote successful round trip
journeys that we are aware of had the
intention of securing an item or a
substance that would have radically
benefited humanity but whether or not
they succeeded in their mission each of
these voyages brought back an
extinction-level threat with them which
is constrained upon them by the guide
prior to their return to the human realm
so let's go over these five known
voyages now the first of which was
conducted by the beccarose Union and
they found themselves on the northeast
shore of Lake mobis the substance they
sought was known as unmanned rock which
had the capacity to generate untold
amounts of electricity when submerged in
water in fact it was even said that a
small bead could output 20 megawatts of
power per day and to put that into some
perspective that is an entire hundred
acre solar farms worth the power so it
would have entirely revolutionized power
consumption unfortunately the unmanned
rock was never acquired as it was held
within the territory of Pat the Beast or
perhaps even beasts plural which insert
part of itself or themselves into the
skull of a human and then proceeds to
slowly feed on them as well as keep them
as pets it's implied that the human
subject to this feel immense pleasure
from the experience of this slow and
torturous existence and if the 1,000
explorers sent out by the beccarose
Union nine hundred ninety three of them
fell victim to PAP and the seven
survivors were forced to bring Pat back
to the human world by the guide as a
lesson and that's going to be a common
consequence as we explore the other
trips next up we have an expedition from
the United States of Sahara which landed
on the north shore of Lake Mobius and
from there they delved into an ancient
Babbitt in search of a herb that was
allegedly able to cure ten thousand
diseases which would have effectively
immunized humanity from disease for
sadly for this expedition though this
labyrinth was the territory of Breann a
species dumped as a botanical weapon
which wiped out all but two members of
the expedition and just as without
previous contenders the guide forced the
survivors to take Brienne back with them
the third trip was conducted by the
Federation of Okemah who decided to
explore the far southeast side of Lake
Mobius and found themselves striving for
some great swampland looking for a form
of food known as nitro rice which is
allegedly the ultimate secret to
longevity the acquisition of which would
have radically expanded the life
expectancy of any being however before
they could even reach these swamps they
encountered a species of snakes known as
the hell bells which decimated 99% of
the explorers of all Chima and leaving
only eleven of them alive and as I'm
sure you can guess by now the guide also
forced these eleven survivors to take
home a souvenir Hill Bell with them for
their efforts on the fourth trip
conducted by the member Republic they
decided to explore an area similar to
that of Ultima except they didn't quite
go as far southeast as them but here
they sought the Trinity elixir which
allegedly could act as a mother solution
to all sorts of liquids but of course
these adventurers also encountered
another extinction-level threat being
the gaseous life-form I which left only
three survivors and even those three
were unable to maintain a single shred
of sanity as a result of their
experience and the final trip was
instigated by the KU canoe Kingdom and
very notably this was the expedition
which beyond Natura was a part of they
landed bang on the southern shore and
we're in search of metallian which was
also known as the alchemy plant now
rather excitedly for the first time the
members of this expedition were actually
able to maintain what they were looking
for but after taking a different route
back the members of the expedition
contracted a disease known as O buying
which unfortunately killed the plant as
well as most of the members of the party
which is kind of interesting because o
buying is known as the immortality
disease despite that it has a
demonstrably high fatality rate upon
contraction although one hunter from B
owns expedition did survive it and he
has now held in a highly secure
containment facility where he has
sustained his life for last 50 years and
is seemingly immune to natural death now
together these five afflictions are
known as the five threats in H seemingly
inflicted upon humanity in retribution
for their actions in visiting the Dark
Continent to begin with
however they certainly aren't the only
life forms on the Dark Continent that
have made their way to humanity the most
well-known of which should be the
chimera ants which eventually produced
their King marijuana's who to this day
is still the most powerful character
displayed in the series furthermore
defeating the chimera ants also cost the
life of Isaac Metro the man who survived
the horrors
the Dark Continent on two separate
occasions and even more scarily that
being known as nanika also originates
from the Dark Continent and just
preemptively before someone tries to
tell me that nanika is not from the Dark
Continent look no it was never said in
the anime but it was revealed in the
manga in one of the extra sections of
volume 33 when Nanako blatantly states I
am from the Dark Continent so that's
that and now while this is pure
speculation I will say that it has been
suggested that nanika was the punishment
forced on net arose on official
expedition as exotic was members of our
party and of course nanika inhabits his
direct descendant Alico zoldak but it's
not all doom and gloom from this area of
the world and the human realm does have
some or inspiring evidence from the Dark
Continent in the form of the World Tree
these are essentially trees that seed
their route into mountain ranges and
grow to absolutely gigantic levels by in
taking magma and such the world tree
that we saw in the series a top of which
gone met his father Jing is but a
sapling that only sauced enough
nutrients to grow to the height of 1784
meters which for our American peeps is
about 1.1 miles high but I do need to
stress that this tree is absolutely
nothing compared to the size of the
world trees on the dark continent and
now with all of this in mind as it
applies to the current story it would
seem that humanity is attempting to
ignore all prior warnings in regards to
traveling to the Dark Continent
and they are doing it again anyway
except this time around it's coming at
the expense of the cocking Empire who
have plans to actually settle all about
continent however the other nations of
the v6 which are now referred to as the
v6 rather than the v5 because they've
since incorporated the cocking Empire
are planning on having the Empire settle
on another landmass which is referred to
as the new continent which is a nother
landmass that exists within like Mobius
meanwhile the actual expedition is only
supposed to consist of approved members
of the form of v5 Nations select
individuals of the hunter Association
and of course beyond network now the
strange thing is that beyonds motives
for wanting to visit the continent a
second time as of right now pretty
unclear although it should be said that
up until this point beyond had been
forbidden from traveling to the
continent again by his father who
proclaimed that he could only do so
after his death furthermore narrow even
in death also sparked the involvement of
the hunter Association as he left them a
video message wishing for them to
explore the Dark Continent and to
provide some benefits for Humanity in
addition to this gene freaks in Paris
turn he'll are also pursuing passage to
the continent for their own individual
reasons and right now they have formed a
tentative alliance would be on
Metro's team so there are a lot of
different factions of play here and this
time around the goal is not as simple as
a big ole group of people heading in
there for one thing and getting
absolutely rekt it's more like a bigger
group of people heading in there for
several different things and probably
getting absolutely wrecked and that's
what those various goals and ambitions
are I'm sad to say that I think it's
going to be an awfully a long time
before we find out however until that
day the Dark Continent will always be
looming in the background as the
ultimate end game for hunter hunter and
that pretty much does it for what we
know of the Dark Continent if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general then please
do consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
sports channel an incredible amount and
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the Dark Continent this has
been the new world of you and I'll see
you next time
you